[Musique]
oh
un jour de toussaint dans le sud
touraine sous un ciel mouvementée le
décor d'automne nous rappelle que le
fief de la dynastie polonaise des bras
ni qui est aussi le théâtre de lugubres
histoires surnaturelles des histoires
venues parfois du moyen-âge et elle
persiste jusqu'à notre époque
frédéric gauthier les collectes il les
raconte des témoignages qui n'en
finissent pas de l'étonner
[Musique]
surinterprétation fait réellement
surnaturel c'est toujours une question
question des questions qui restent en
suspens où chacun peut se faire son
opinion mais on va dire qu'il ya des
gens qui ont aujourd'hui encore on
l'impression de lui des choses un
caractère surnaturel
le sud touraine serait-il alors une
terre choisi pour des manifestations
extraordinaire comme une nuit de 1980
une mère et son fils auraient observé
une présence extraterrestre la sphère
aurait fait grand bruit à l'époque
vous savez que le geipan recense recense
en france toutes ces affaires un peu
bizarre et on dit lâche hambourg sur un
des chances au près loches aurait été
aperçue une fois une forme triangulaire
dans le ciel est une fois une forme plus
habituel lirez d'ovni
circulaire dans le ciel d'anciennes le
choix
fantôme extraterrestres et sorcellerie
puisque dès le moyen-age on condamnait
localement au péché
croire au mauvais sort à la vie dure car
aujourd'hui encore certains désagréments
lui sont attribués
les histoires de mauvais sorts de
sorcier
il sort quand j'étais sur le voisin
c'est des choses qui ont perduré au dire
au moins jusqu'au début du 20e siècle et
peut-être même qu encore
quelques habitants croient c'est à ces
sorciers ou ces personnes qui peuvent
vouloir du mal et vous jeter un sort
et ça n'est pas la visite du château du
comte slave qui réchauffera l'atmosphère
si le diable vous accueille dans les
jardins les intérieurs dont frédéric
gauthier connaît toute l'histoire vous
rappelleront que lou rapaces gibier
impressionnant et autres félins
rugissants sont autant de symboles des
forces de la nature et de l'esprit